just because you know how it may end
doesn't mean that the journey is not
valuable either so i think
predictability is a tough one to
to um ask because it's not all or
nothing either
why are movies so predictable these days
i think that there's a couple reasons
one is
uh the amount of content that is out now
and
uh i think it gives us the impression
that movies are all predictable
when maybe it's just
the
movies that we're watching
that you know or like the things that we
think uh or the movies that uh have the
big releases if that's the question
are they predictable um
and yeah i think they're they can that
in that sense um
i think that's partially engineered to
uh just how the system works uh in a way
i mean
those you know people are getting
oh let's do this franchise um there's
there's familiarity in
and uh maybe the predictability of
certain things
maybe that's what people makes people
comfortable maybe that's what is drawing
in them
millions of dollars from a studio
executive's side that's putting up 100
or 200 million dollars to make that
movie you know they have to play those
things safe
in theory
i don't know if that's true but i can at
least understand why
they may be predictable
um
independent cinema and uh
you know maybe some of the
lower
tier budget types of films i think like
should
take those chances to to do some
uh do things differently to not be
predictable
um and i think that the ones that are
successful generally
um are because they're not but maybe
that's
there's also a lot to weed through to
get there too
um i don't think that movies are all
predictable
but uh but i think that the ones that
were
that were barraged with often
are and as an independent filmmaker i
have a i'm struggling with this even on
my scent the side of of it just
like how do you get a film out there so
that people want to watch it
it versus people going to the
predictable movie is a challenge for all
of us really
and uh
yeah i mean i don't think that movies
are all predictable but
i think there are reasons why we think
that they are
and
many of them really are too and it's
just kind of what we're
exposed to sometimes as well
but you mentioned that you've been
watching
movies that you hadn't seen in many
years because in some sense whether
there was a nostalgia there or you felt
just the storytelling was better yeah um
i think there's both um
you know
i mean but you can't make these movies
today
without them think you know people would
think that they're predictable also like
i mean um
like what did i just watch the other day
uh the fugitive
uh with harrison ford
and
i i'm like i love that movie is it a
movie if you made it exactly the same
way today would people like it i don't
know i really don't think so it's just
that i remember having a great
experience watching that as a kid and
that's what you know but i do think it's
really well made and it and you know
tommy jones got an academy reward and
all this stuff
and that movie was also a movie i know
was saved in the edit too
uh so that's some information i did not
know when i was seven and when i saw it
but of course i'm i i find those things
fascinating and also you know some of
this is valuable uh maybe or
like
i grew up in the age of dvds and
uh director's commentaries where you get
to listen to all this stuff none of that
exists really anymore and i kind of miss
all of that and i think that there's a
disconnect between
the the the movies that we're watching
which just seem maybe cookie cutter as
you as you just as you were asking me
about earlier
uh because of the sheer volume and
all the streamers and everything that's
just they have to put up new stuff every
two days to keep subscribers or whatever
it is that they think that but there's
also no way for me to really
get involved with like
that like that kind of like personal
connection that i felt like i had when i
was younger as a up-and-coming like you
know student in filmmaking and things
like that where like i've listened to
every
single uh commentary and
you know behind the scenes interview and
all that stuff and i just don't see it
anymore i'm not sure where
and why that is it's just the way films
are distributed now i guess but
that's kind of where like you know uh
um watching
uh
i know like uh you know the fugitive and
and like apollo 13. like i have a lot of
movies that that i i just kind of like
gravitate towards
uh like dances with uh wolves
is another one where it's just like that
familiarity to me it just brings me back
to a place where i'm reminded of what it
felt like as a kid to be inspired by
these things because sometimes i get
jaded by the industry i'm
i'm working in because it's just a
constant you know it's it's my life now
and sometimes i need to like take a step
back and
just be like why did i do this
oh yeah it's because of this moment in
this movie when i was eight you know
are there things that filmmakers or
writers can do to make their films less
predictable uh
well i think that depends on what the
type of movie is that you're talking
about
you know um some movies yeah you do want
the here to win sometimes you want to be
taken on a ride sometimes you want to
uh
you know the hero needs to die for the
the
um
uh for the theme to come through or
whatever you know what i mean like
there's all sorts of different reasons
and predictability
is you know that's also
sometimes a little bit um
just
like subjective really i mean like oh
like so you knew that the guy was gonna
catch the girl
two minutes before is that predictable
or is it
uh
you know or or is it that you knew that
the that maximus was gonna die at the
end of gladiator you know what i mean
like yeah but of course but he had to
have died to like uh for that story to
have it's it's like potency and and kind
of emotional weight and but yeah just
because you know how it may end doesn't
mean that the journey is not valuable
either so i think predictability is a
tough one to
to um ask because it's not all or
nothing either um for me at least like
i'm okay with going down a journey that
i may have an idea of how it might end
but how i got there might change whether
i thought it was predictable or not you
know what i mean
um of course it's our job to take the
audience on a ride as filmmakers as
writers as editors as directors
and um
how we can
ensure that i think
it really kind of starts in the script
honestly and
you know sometimes you're working on
something that you don't have any say
and all that but if you're if you are a
screenwriter
um i think there's a balance between
getting paid to write something versus
what you're writing to get noticed
right everybody from my understanding in
this industry is like
you know
knock my like socks off with your spec
script but then that will get you hired
and then they're going to make you write
it like this and this and this because
of x y and z whatever that is so there's
an aspect of the business that's just
part of that process
you